ukraine playing scotland tonight
actually aren't they up in scotland who
do you want to win i always support the
british team i'm afraid but uh i hope
the ukrainians play well as well okay
there we go um talk to me as i said big
guns are out today what's the atmosphere
like at the top at the moment do you
know what it's fine and of course
there's all the westminster froth and
i'm not
decrying uh the importance of the issues
at hand but the reality is um we've got
a load of big issues we're grappling
with and less than two years to the next
election i think we can all
say given the time limits we've got the
cost of living package out the 15
billion pounds rishi sonic announced
there's all these issues you've just
been reporting on in ukraine and i think
the prime minister's leadership has been
critical to that i'm very focused i've
been talking this week about the efforts
we're getting to ramp up work
for prisoners to get them uh on the
straight and narrow and to cut
re-offending and
there's been all the distractions at
partygate i think the accountability has
been addressed i think the transparency
has been addressed we're getting on with
the job i think that's what our
constituents expect should uh prisoners
be allowed to celebrate the jubilee
and i said this i was in h p exeter and
i think uh that if uh prisoners for
example i was icing cupcakes with union
jack
[Music]
baubles and things on them
and of course i was and that's a part of
the klinks restaurant in prisons which
i've quadrupled the number in prisons
and it gives offenders
the skills to get jobs on release and we
know they're a third less likely to
reoffend so bottom line it makes our
streets safer actually if offenders are
willing to take a second chance to turn
their lives around and start doing
constructive things and if taking part
in the jubilee celebrations gives them a
bit of positive motivation in that
regard i don't think it's a bad thing
okay back to partygate
the
pm
must be worried about his future despite
what you're saying especially given what
we've heard from lord guy who says he
believes um that the prime minister has
potentially broken the ministerial code
after being fined for a lockdown breach
why do you think he hasn't
well the lord gate raised that issue and
the pm has responded to it the letter
and he's been clear that in relation to
the single fixed penalty notice he
hadn't intentionally broken the law and
his attendance at that gathering has
been well rehearsed was inadvertent so
lord gate is really important he's a
senior figure we've actually been
working for months to reinforce his role
uh that's been done by agreement between
number 10 and lord guy but actually i
think those questions have been answered
both
in general but also now specifically in
the letter the pms sent and as i said
we're getting on with the job cost of
living economy but you have just
acknowledged that the prime minister
broke the law and that's against the
ministerial code not quite that simple
because um there have been examples in
the past i i'm not sure raking over all
the precedence is particularly helpful
but there are where uh similarly i
remember baroness scotland um i think
it's 2009. yeah she wasn't prime
minister though no but she was a
minister and these rules are meant to
apply equally and the point was she
hadn't acted deliberately or
intentionally therefore gordon brown uh
took the view that uh the code hadn't
been broken so i'm just saying there are
precedents for this and i explain the
specific reasons why
in the absence of deliberately uh
breaking uh the code or doing something
deliberately
and i think it's clear uh from the
circumstances of this particular
gathering where he turned up um was
there for ten minutes was unaware uh
that it was uh a surprise birthday cake
for him and all the stuff that's been
well rehearsed i don't think that was a
deliberate attempt a deliberate breach
of the rules and that's the key point
but it is breaking the law and that is
against the ministerial code it's it's
not that simple actually um
oh and i think the people guy thinks it
is no he's asking the actually in
fairness what i think laura geith raised
was um why in the house of commons this
hadn't been explicitly addressed now of
course in the house of commons and i was
there next to the pm he's asked
questions more sides of the house
they'll focus on the bits they want to
focus on but it's a legitimate point to
seek clarification on the pm's provided
it and as i say i missed all of this
process which has now been going on for
a long time and every question i think
has been fairly
answered by the pm we're getting on with
the job and i do think i do think uh
that that's what our uh constituents
that's what the public expect and
there's a lot on the government's plate
with the cost of living with ukraine the
law enforcement
the crime-fighting agenda
but we're not ducking those issues pm
has not done those issues he's addressed
them squarely but there could be a vote
of no confidence or a vote of confidence
depending on which way you look at it as
early as next week that according to
william hague who says um he thinks that
boris johnson's in real trouble
i look uh i i like william hague i
respect him but he's a commentator in
the telegraph now and of course a senior
um
figure in his own right and previous
leader of the conservative party but i'm
just not going to comment on the country
that's not my job as deputy prime
minister it's not my job as a member of
parliament to serve my constituents and
that's what we're doing on the cost of
living on crime fighting and on
the situation in ukraine which needs
very careful uh management at a very
sensitive time as well do you think that
we could find ourselves in a position
where there is a vote of confidence in
the prime minister as early as next week
no
why i just don't see i look i allow me
to just give you my view i think the
westminster the bubble and village whips
this stuff up i'm not saying it's not
serious and significant but we've dealt
with all of those issues the prime
minister's dealt with all those issues
it does feel like
a lot of commentary uh building up this
issue when actually when i talked to mps
um and
when i talked across the house of
commons about the issues that i'm taking
forward a new victims bill parole reform
bill of rights the crime fighting agenda
particularly rehabilitation
in prisons they they want to see us
driving forward that agenda and to be
honest with you votes for no confidence
leadership contests all of that is yet
more westminster talking to itself not
talking to the public not talking to our
constituents i think the vast majority
of mps
respect recognise and agree with that
that the two people in in the house of
commons who want a leadership contest
who talk about it every time we announce
the comments a kiss starmer and ian
blackford for the smp and at least 40 of
your mps but but they're not asking for
it because they think it's in the public
interest or indeed in the conservative
interest they think there's some
political gain for them in doing so and
again that's a point which i think
senior members of the parliamentary
party also make and at least 40 of your
mps
at least 40 of my mps want a leadership
um challenge
i i look uh i don't know what the
numbers i don't think anyone does i i
doubt it's that high really in terms of
letters but the truth is i don't know
but the reality is there's uh you know
over 350 conservative mps um and i think
that the rema the the overwhelming
swathe of the party recognized well i'm
saying which is our constituents the
public wants to get on the job all the
people
who want to see us in a leadership
contest
most are on the other side of the
benches in the house of commons labour
and the smp yeah but
it looks as though it's what certainly
by the end of the month is what many of
your colleagues are saying i couldn't
possibly know that perhaps perhaps as
early as next week how can you possibly
know that it won't be i don't know why
did you say no i can't prove this i
can't prove a negative to uk and you're
always the most girlful of uh
interviewers don't i mean that in a
positive okay i'll take it in a positive
way then but the reality is all i'm
telling you um because i
talk to mps every day because i talk to
the whole range
of mps um on all sides of the party uh
and i know what they're saying to me um
might be saying something just different
to somebody else though it could be and
but of course the media will magnify the
negative votes oh it's always the
meaning would you say that i didn't say
that i was being fair and judicious okay
i'm just saying i i i think sometimes
the silent majority do get neglected a
little bit by the media okay covet style
news conferences on the economy when are
they going to start i don't know that
will be for um the comms team number 10
to uh decide but i do think that so they
are going to happen i look i don't know
that so comes uh uh
uh
for the director of communications and
and the team there but actually making
sure we are delivering for people with
the cost of living is really important
we've got the inquiry the cut in
national insurance coming in july tell
me about the 15 billion again no i was
going to tell you about the tax cut uh
for national insurance coming in july
and then the 400 pound uh
cash grant for paying energy bills in
october and the fact that we just need
to be making sure not just that we're
delivering but also demonstrating what
we're doing for people struggling to
make ends meet as a result of your first
answer it made me think are you
suggesting that potentially we could
have an early election no
definitely not i think it's very
unlikely okay and i think by the way
when the election comes we'll win it of
course you do you wouldn't say otherwise
would you um travel chaos um what on
earth is happening well do you know what
the first thing to say is it's good news
that more holiday makers got the
confidence
post covered pandemic to say okay you
know we're going to book these flights
has obviously been a surge in demand
throughout the pandemic the government
provides i think he's 8 billion pounds
of support there's been some tweaks to
the regulation to make it easier for the
airline industry to hire and and i think
also there's clearly
been a a
a lack of preparation for that surge
back of demand of holiday makers and
grant chaps has been taught the
transport secretary has been talking to
the industry
for months now saying that this will
come and and that you need to make sure
you've got your recruitment in place um
so i know that there's a bit of finger
pointing going on at the moment but
that's the support and that's the advice
i mean whose fault is it that kids are
sleeping on the floor at stanston
airport i don't think the airline
operators have uh uh have done the
recruitment that they should have done
and taken the advice that the transport
secretary gave them okay uh there's some
suggestions that aviation bosses want to
access tax records that would help them
to recruit staff more quickly rather
than going back through all of the
previous employers is that something the
government will look at so i don't know
the details of that but i do know that
we've made some changes uh on the
regulatory front because we know that
there's
a demand for
recruitment and we want to help the
airline industry deal with that look i
think it's again it's good news
holidaymakers have got the confidence to
be taking these trips and holidays and
we do not want to see the scenes or the
reports as you mentioned and people
having to sleep in airports and we want
to work with the industry to facilitate
that but again in terms of some of the
finger pointing the transport sector has
been talking to the sector for some time
now saying you you need to get on with
the recruitment to make sure that you've
got the capacity because this demand is
coming back yeah i mean it's we're being
told but that it's likely to get just
looking at the pictures that it's likely
to get worse before it gets better what
can the government do today to help
people
actually but why do we we always seem to
do that it's actually for the sector to
address what is a a better problem to
have than falling demand which is
increasing demand but we are providing
the support we've already provided the
support and and of course i'm sure if
there are
smart things that we can do together
with the sector to ease the way and make
it easier for holiday makers of course
we want to do that when are we sending
the asylum seekers to rwanda
i don't know exactly there's been talk
of um next month where the home sector
is working on the operational
matters to get that first flight going i
think it will be important i think
people will see then that you don't have
the automatic right to come by an
unlawful route to the uk without the
risk of finding yourself uh in a in a
different destination i rwanda
and i'm not saying it's the whole piece
around this i've never said that i do
think it's an important piece of the
jigsaw of dealing with this cruel trade
and human misery by those who want to
exploit unlawful routes in this country
which we can't be allowing and are you
completely comfortable that they are
syrians who are going to be sent to
rwanda i i don't know the nationality
but are you completely comfortable if
they are which we believe they are well
again i'm not going to comment on
something that i don't have the facts on
but i'm very confident that we'll do
this in the right way we'll have the
right processes human rights compliant
and that rwanda will be able to deal
with these in
in a decent humane way okay what are you
going to do for the jubilee
i've got lots of jubilee parties it's
quite fun i think the community is
coming together um my street is having a
street party and for me in particular my
boys are six and nine it's quite
interesting seven and nine sorry um goes
so quickly
uh it just got quite nice seeing the
patriotism and their involvement my mum
was sending me some pictures of 1977 and
me and i'm not going to show you these
pictures of me waving oh too if you got
on your phone maybe later
which shirt which channel will you be
watching sky of course okay that's what
we needed to hear thank you very much
indeed deputy prime minister thank you